Good morning.
Hello folks.
We're live.
We have stuff to look at today. Lots and
lots of stuff to look at today. So
um first of all experiments.
Yes we have experiments.
I've left this running for quite a while
now.
Interesting.
a good number of these
as we can see.
I don't really want to pick a uh 20
minute run to repro, do I?
This one's pretty good.
27K in uh less than 10 minutes.
Genial oath.
Let's grab this one.
Oh, and for reference um so people can
just see how utterly stupid the number
of experiments we've run is here.
Okay, this is 300 experiments
and uh if I just sort this by steps
here,
I don't even know how much data this is.
This is like an ungodly amount of data.
average experiment is probably somewhere
in here.
So,
I don't know, 250 billion steps worth of
experiments in the last day, day and a
half on one GPU.
Honestly, it could have been more than
that as well. It was using pretty big
networks.
Hello, Pepe. Welcome.
Wish my chat could be um wish you could
see my chat a little better.
And we're going to just move the chat
today so I can have it here. That'll be
easier to see.
I have the uh the perfect monitor set
up.
Finally.
All right. So,
let's grab this experiment
and
So, where was I yesterday as well? Well,
I was going to end up doing some client
work. Um, but then clients didn't get me
the thing that I needed uh that they
needed to get me in order for me to do
the work for them.
And I did about two hours of hard gym
training. I was too tired to stream. So
instead, I did about six hours worth of
profiling work
on puffer 4 and I cleaned up a bunch of
stuff.
That's what I did instead.
And I think that things are pretty
stable now.
So, let's see if we can uh
can grab some hypers from here. Yeah.
Well, let's see.
There's two
and two.
are Yeah, the betas are very close but a
little bit different.
This is going to be nice. So, we got
beta one, we got beta 2.
We're not going to have to be doing this
manually for much longer because we're
going to be porting everything to
constellation.
Uh, very very sketchy with the clip
coefficients being that
that small, but hey, that's fine.
As long as it's stable training,
reasonable ant
We have lots to learn from these
experiments.
Learning rates very stable.
Same uh we basically got the same
learning rate back for multiple runs.
Big replay ratio.
Very odd.
Or decently fast.
That's a good thing.
Is this the best run? Yes, it is. But we
have more things like we have more
tricks to play.
No buffers on threads.
Total agent is 16k.
All right.
Hi Manny. Remember you gave
me advice for 231 has worked so well.
completed all the lesson assignments.
Very good. Actually prints good papers,
physically read them, try to write stuff
down, try to implement them first from
scratch in PyTorch. What do you think I
should do next? A bit confused. Well,
you've actually done stuff correctly
because that's pretty much how I
learned. Um,
if you're actually doing this all
formally, it seems like you have the
discipline to get somewhere with it,
which is very good. Um, so
really now I what I would suggest you to
read is first of all go reread my
programming and science article assuming
you've read it once
because it like even if you've read it I
think you'll actually be able to you'll
be able to actually make use of this
advice a lot better.
I'm going to take a couple minutes since
that you put in the effort. Um,
look
this section right here. Okay, really
really internalize especially this these
sections here. Really really internalize
this. Um
because the thing that you're going to
run into now is you're going to try to
replicate stuff and you're going to feel
stupid if you can't when a lot of the
time it's because a lot of the science
is very sloppy.
So from here uh you're at a point where
you can decide either specialization or
an area of particular interest to you.
So I mean I have the general advice for
RL and it's even very specific advice
for RL right I have my article here
that's this is how I would suggest to go
into RL it has a papers list that I
think is quite good it has some stuff to
actually build to get involved like this
has you essentially building
environments that are useful enough to
advance research and this is pretty much
a direct on-ramp to advancing the field
now I'm no longer focused on academic
and publishing. So my focus is on the
work that matters regardless of that
type of stuff. Um this is a very good
guide for that. For publishing there is
a separate skill set on writing papers
and understanding academic discourse
including all the [ __ ] that comes
with it.
uh for language modeling work and like
the modern uh modern that whole
zeitgeist
things are a little harder because you
have to be looking for things that you
can actually do productively
uh without
without a ton of compute. There are some
things that you can do. Probably the
best example of this recently was uh
muong
which was you know this optimizer that
was just a standalone contribution. It
was very well tested at relatively small
scale. It was useful everywhere. Uh that
was a very math heavy contribution like
that was one of the rare cases where
having a heavy math background was very
very useful for that. Uh other things
you know like what I'm doing with puffer
I don't need compute. It's an
engineering heavy contribution.
There are also things you can just do
with architecture that just depend on
doing good basic science. There are a
lot of opportunities really. there
opportunities pretty much anywhere that
nobody has properly looked.
So I guess it really depends on like
what do you want to do now that you've
learned some AI, right? What's your
goal? Because there are a lot of ways
you could go and now you have you
essentially have the baseline
requirements to at least start.
discussion on LM's lacking world models.
So
I world models are not the fix cuz world
models are like
it's just next token prediction again in
a different modality.
I don't think world models are the big
missing component. They can help but in
RL specifically world models in RL are a
complete disaster.
regularly read your old article multiple
times showing that this is my most
viewed one I've read and applied all
points there an actual one not much
interest just love building actual stuff
on the building side do you recommend
well I guess it depends what you're
interested in right I can speak to RL
specifically right like in RL RL's kind
of wholesome right now because it
heavily rewards you for learning lower
level dev so if you're interested in
performance engineering ing. It's
incredibly helpful. I think RL is an
area where there's really not that much
attention being paid to this type of
stuff, but it has this ludicrously high
potential because we can literally train
on pabytes of simulation data. We're
going to be able to build simulation d
simulations across a wide variety of
domains. uh there's algorithmic side
research to be done as well that is very
important and there are many good ideas
out there that have just been executed
very poorly because of poor engineering.
So if that's the way you like to lean
into things, then it's very it's like a
very promising field, but you don't have
to go with my uh my sub area, right?
Like you can go do stuff in vision and
NLP as well. It's just there isn't a
puffer lip for vision and NLP and uh and
CV, right? Like you kind of have to go
forge your own path there.
And that's mainly identifying it's
identifying gaps in methods, identifying
gaps in approaches and data and like
finding areas where people have missed
stuff missed massively. That's where you
make large contributions.
You know, stuff like imageet back in the
day,
like computer vision didn't really get
serious until there was a big data set
where people could say, "Oh, this thing
actually works when we have the data for
it. Cool. This is worth pursuing."
I think RL fell off because everybody
wrote it so slow that we couldn't see it
working on a variety of problems.
So, I made puffer, right?
You have the basic like you have the
basics down though now if you've done
both of those. I mean if you've done all
that stuff you've got the basics down.
You could go build an RL environment or
two to see if you find it interesting.
Um, and you can see if you'd like to get
into some of the research work there or
you could go try something in CV or NLP.
I don't have as good of a guide there
though, right? Like I have some idea of
what papers actually work but not really
much for the modern stuff.
Really annoying bit is I have not seen
um small transformers.
I really haven't seen like much work on
small transformers you can train on a
single GPU being effective.
Maybe there is some work I'm just not
aware of seeing.
that's about as good of an answer as
I've got for you.
Okay. 300 experiment sweep is completed.
What
This is very cool. I think this is
probably the only lab I'm kind of
excited about.
I have to look into more of what they've
done.
Let's go see if we uh first of all this
is training 1.6 6 mil SPS for the 4 mil
perm model. That is with 2x sample
reuse.
And that is with 2x sample views.
Where's our score?
Oh, yeah. This is tracking perfectly so
far. Good.
So, we'll run this quick repro because
it's not going to take very long. And
then we're going to a new architecture
thing. NanoGpts. NanoGPT is a very very
good thing to be looking at.
Let me specialize on one thing.
Complete ML and not only DL. I've read
books.
The Elon's thing is if you've read his
like Walter Isacson bio, it's
that guy does a lot.
I think there are very very few people
like him. Um,
and I do
you really just have to not get too
tired at the end of the day. I don't
know. You have to have unlimited energy
to do that stuff.
I think then um if you want to do a lot
of things,
I'm probably in a position where I could
do a lot of things, but it's because
I've spent a lot of time developing one
core broadly applicable skill, right?
like
being able to do uh to make complex
problems simple through low-level
performance engineering that is very
widely applicable. I could probably take
the approach I've done with Puffer and
throw it at a bunch of different
problems and it would probably work very
well.
So in some sense, right, like it's fine
to do a bunch of things, but you
actually have to have a competence that
makes you suited to do many of those
things, right?
So you do need to have a deep competence
because otherwise a lot of the
generalists just end up not really doing
anything
right like generalist also just becomes
a word for I don't actually know how to
do anything.
The good news for you though is um well
complete ML I've really seen much like
there's
everything these days is deep learning
in some variety for the most part I I
guess the good news for you is it's very
easy to jump around from problem to
problem in deep learning that used to
not be the case with earlier ML right
there used to be very specialized NLP
systems and very specialized vision
systems and whatnot
So, it's gotten a lot easier in some
sense.
I mean, low-level engine is good. Basic
science is good if you've got the
aptitude for it. Math is good.
Is this just RNG? Why is this one now
suddenly better than this one?
I'll show you all what I'm going to do
next though with this. So,
I'm trying to think when I did this.
When did I kick off this run? Today is
Monday.
Do I have this thing running on
Saturday,
you know, I actually don't remember
whether I had um
this encoder here. I actually don't
remember
if we had this one on or not.
when I kicked off this run.
I guess we can maybe check.
Does it log the number of parameters?
Maybe I already did this sweep with the
encoder.
I basically I don't remember whether I
have this stupid thing like set up false
whatever
this simple encoder here
Close on score, but actually not that
close.
All right, let's try this one. Maybe
this was the thing.
and this adds a few more params.
Basically same speed.
So we'll see if this makes a difference.
But we have the difference here.
And this encoder just has
embedding
I mean, this should this should actually
matter, you know.
It'd be kind of surprising if this
didn't make a big difference.
Oh, is this already up above? I can't
tell.
Huh.
This is under in sport at the moment.
Weird.
Yeah, it sounds like you've got a a
crazy amount of energy. I know a couple
people like this. I mean, the main thing
is to just be sure that you're directing
it at something that you think is
actually going to be productive, right?
That's usually the main downfall. Like,
having a ton of energy is such a huge
blessing.
It's honestly the main limiting factor
is I do not have enough energy to do the
stuff that I do all day, all day, all
day.
Um, so just make sure you know you're
directing it at at reasonable stuff.
Well, this curve is definitely
different, right?
This is a very different curve.
So, presumably both of the previous runs
then were on um
both of the previous runs. We're on the
flat network.
It actually doesn't make sense. This
would be worse though, does it?
it really need different hypers for a
different encoder? It shouldn't, right?
Yeah, we're not reaching 32K at all
either.
I mean, I guess it's not entirely um
discrete encoding.
Oh, look at this. Interestingly,
the rerun actually got 65k a few times.
if we go by 65k completions,
it's the best run that we have.
It's the one that runs under a million
SPS.
And the score has actually gone down on
this one.
That's so screwy.
It actually does worse with the
embeddings.
Yeah, this is just unstable.
Okay, that's probably a bad one with
which to evaluate stuff then.
all the best runs have clip coefficient
0.01.
I've got enough proper intuition. Well,
that's how that's how you get some basic
intuition, Arian,
Oh,
wait. Did I do
did I get the ratio wrong? I think I did
get the ratio wrong.
Try one more time with um one thing
fixed.
Okay, we can run one more just for the
heck of it. I doubt that that makes a
difference, but um
just very weird.
go to build an RL. Yeah, I mean it's it
doesn't walk you through like step by
step build this exact project, but it
does walk you through the steps of like
this is how you build up from something
smaller to larger, etc.
I mean, take a look through it, right?
See if it interests you.
It's a very good way to learn.
Okay. So, other than this experiment, uh
we want to just clean up a whole bunch
of stuff in Popper today, right?
I'm going to use the restroom to do a
couple quick things while this runs
and um
then we will commence on the refactors.
I should be back.
I DM you and ask for feedback once I
finish or uh meet me on here. Sometimes
my DMs get flooded and I don't see
stuff, you know.
Streaming tons.
Yeah, this is not super promising, is
it? Here.
we got reasonably good results from the
sweep at the least.
I don't think we did anywhere near as
well as um as the originals though, but
we could run it for longer. We're
running it for like 1 second of the
time, so
it's okay.
>> Profiling and stuff.
>> Oh, absolutely. Perfect timing.
Wait, how on earth do you have it
working in both precisions?
I made it static build so you have to
rebuild it for a specific Oh, okay. With
the setup flag.
Yeah, that's how it works.
Oh, you got us a lot of good stats,
didn't you? Whole eight.
Let me see if I can understand all
these. So,
This isn't roll out copy though. What
are these sections?
So roll out copy is it's a set of copy
ops. This is part of training. This is
part of training. This is a different
copy op in training.
One mini bag operation.
Really? 300 microsconds worth of copying
per mini?
That's really slow.
How on earth could it possibly be like
that? Wait.
Messaging Discord. Yeah, let me get
Discord open. I'll put um there's
nothing. Yeah, let me let me put this on
the screen so we can just
do that.
If you check profile folder, there's all
discrete files. Okay, hold on. Let's go
see that.
We're going to check both of Oops. That
is not at all what I wanted to do.
So, let's do it this way.
Easier.
Oops.
That's right.
and then 750.
Backward takes twice as long as forward.
That's kind of reasonable, right?
encoder.
Use scan decoder.
Wait, training breakdown.
I don't understand that. Oh, wait.
Because this is just the training step.
Is this actually this is 200
microsconds, huh? This just this um
train select and copy.
I mean, this is ridiculous here. If
we're losing three like almost 400
microsconds, this is nothing.
Like this should like this is a nothing
op. So we're losing a lot of time like
50% training overhead still, right?
And if you profile this unwrapped, it
might be very different
unap. Okay. Well, definitely that should
not be unagraphed profile.
They get graphed, don't they? Oh, maybe
they don't. Actually, you're probably
right that they don't. [ __ ]
Wait, can you explain what?
I did a whole bunch of work to get the
logic duped out of here. Like it looks
like you have the logic of these ops
duped again, right?
Like we should not be duping the logic
of our ops in the tests.
Okay, that's actually probably good
finding then because
this getting graphed would probably get
us a little bit of speed.
I'm also generally not a huge fan of
having a ton of little files for
testing.
Um, you did you did actually get us some
very nice results though for this
because I somehow missed that compute.
All right, let's let me bounce some
ideas off of you here because you have
some good stuff here and then some stuff
I don't get quite yet. Um,
so this was kind of my initial vision of
the testing, right? We've got two
different things we can do.
We have two different options for
testing.
The first is if you set the profile
equals true tag.
We've got these like pretty lightweight
NVXT tags
and VTX tags. I mean
you see these like profile start profile
end these things.
So this lets you profile during
training.
And then we separately had profiling for
individual ops
in the profiles call the profile call.
Let me look at your timing data first
though because I think that I I think
there's like a whole bunch from your
timing data I didn't understand.
profile rollupcopy.cu.
Okay, let's go look at this one.
Oh, okay. So, this is this is not roll
out.
Is this this is the train time copy
function. Okay, I see.
So wait, why is this not add up remotely
to this?
Discrete files just for readability.
I'm usually not a fan of having a bunch
of files. The reason for it is every
time you end up splitting stuff into
more files, you end up getting more
code. When you have all your code in one
file, you're forced to look at the
amount of lines of code you have. And
then you have some sense of whether you
have too many lines of code for the task
you're accomplishing.
I mean, either way, this is like awful,
awful, awful overhead, right?
So, unfortunately, the thing is that
this right here, this is unavoidable.
So the reason that we have this overhead
here, it's because of this indexing off,
right? So this is a view and then this
is a um strided copy or like a
non-ontiguous copy.
This is I think unavoidable based on how
we have our sampling in the current
algorithm.
It is possibly worth graphing the
It's possibly worth drafting this
operation, I would think.
Why the hell's compute advantage this
slow?
Wait, was this Were you the one that had
a PR for the advantage function?
We literally got somebody PR this
before.
I didn't merge it because it was kind of
confusing to me.
Yeah, it was this one here.
Oh, yeah. This is your PR
Does this break if it's not a like does
this break? H
Wait, why the hell is this kernel slow
in the first place?
Oh, actually, we do call this on a lot
of data, don't we?
Well, we definitely want this to be
fast.
I just like how much more complicated
this is.
It's just annoying how much more
complicated this is, right?
Like, did you test how much of this is
from the unroll versus how much of this
is from the loading and stuff?
Because the annoying thing to about this
to me, right, is that like
this is a mathematically pretty fancy
operation here.
And um
well, I guess this doesn't pollute the
main path of the code.
52 microsconds is a lot.
But then how the hell is compute? All
right, Jonah, before we do this, I want
to understand like why the heck these
don't add up because that's like a
really big discrepancy. So I want to
make sure that there's actually savings
here.
Float four helps. I would believe it,
but I want to verify it because these
not adding up is sketchy to me. So, if
we can shave a good chunk off of
training time between this and then
graphing the pryo, that'd be awesome. I
looked at trying to write a kernel for
pryo. I think writing a kernel for pryo
is very annoying, right?
Because like
it's um
there are a bunch of reduction
operations in here, right? There's the
sum, the like multinomial. There are a
bunch of reductions.
So, it's probably pretty annoying to
write a kernel for this.
And I don't even know if it's worth it.
Like this this op should be pretty fast.
I also don't know if we're keeping like
this whole prioritize replay thing might
just be gone next update anyways. So,
it's probably not worth doing too much
crazy on this. It's probably worth
cudggraphing it. And that's about it.
Actually, that's a pretty easy thing for
you to play with. If you want to figure
out the um the profile and then maybe
see if this is worth cudggraphing,
that would be a good thing to do.
Cuz right here, this would save us. How
much does this save us?
like 20% on training, maybe
10%. That's like another mil SPS
probably.
Yeah, that's good.
Are you proud of stuff? All right. Now,
as for
let's talk a little bit about the
structure of all this stuff real quick.
So
whether it's one file or multiple files,
it's very easy for us to screw with,
right?
All right. First of all, even if we are
going to have the code be duplicated in
the test, we sure as hell should not
have it be duplicated in the test
multiple times. This is ridiculous,
right?
Um,
now as for whether it should be
duplicated in the first place.
The uh the difficulty I have with this
is as much as Oops. as much as possible.
I um I like to have the code written top
to bottom in the simplest way possible
with minimum breaking out into functions
for things that are only used once.
It's much easier to just read the whole
train loop that way.
See, like if I split these out into
functions, it's like the code gets
worse.
Heck, this compute train loss even,
right? Um,
you know what? I've given you two things
to do for now because I'm going to be I
have a few hours today to spend cleaning
stuff up anyways. So, let me see how I'm
liking the state of the codebase after
that. Um if you can just look at
figuring out where that discrepancy is
coming from and then maybe depending on
that the um
advantage kernel and the pryo if that if
a graphing helps you'll probably get us
an extra mil SPS just doing that which
is already a nice contribution and then
we'll come back to like the structure
and organization of everything
profiling is different for discrete
versus full because All discrete ops
doing its own profile
does warmups
profile kernel which does warm-ups and
whatnot to synchronizes.
There shouldn't be cuda synchronizes
though, right? Look,
you don't have cuda synchronizes.
That's why I'm confused.
So if we look in roll out copy,
you actually have
where is it?
There's no synchronizes here, man.
These are NVTX ranges
in profile kernel
inprofile.h.
Wait, what?
Oh man, this is why having split.
Uh,
You're only synchronizing in every batch
check, right?
So you're literally you're not
synchronizing at every iteration.
If this is too small, that would just be
bad on the test, right?
but run full rollup copies fold as the
function arc to profile kernel.
Run full rollout copy.
Scroll all the way back down.
This doesn't have any synchronized snip
though, man. What are you talking about?
These NVTX ranges don't sync. These
should be very lightweight.
So in my mind I I still don't see um I
don't see where the overhead is coming
from
based on this.
These don't synchronize. This doesn't
like none of these synchronize.
So the only thing that gets synchronized
is every like batch whatever iterations
of pro the call and profile at age
All right.
discrepancy comes from the full run.
Oops. Let me get rid of this bot in my
chat real quick.
benchmarks a good way to get into RL
without jumping into training.
Uh David, you can train because Popper
will train in seconds. So on like a
lowend GPU, you can do both
revive robotics. What?
Uh let's see. Discrepancy comes from run
full roll out copy run through the
function. It runs as a single function.
It runs as a single function.
They all needing to cuda synchronize do
their warm-ups.
But I don't
the warm-ups don't get timed, right?
I still don't understand that. The
warm-ups don't get timed like
here.
If anything, it should be faster with
the individual profiles because they
have better caching.
Okay, look the start here doesn't
include warm up, right?
Tim timing start
stop.
Wait, is this is this test wrong? Let me
see.
Uh, the test is wrong, right?
Event record.
I think this is including the warm-up,
right?
Hey Jess, I've got um I've got Jonah
here on the side in Discord so he
doesn't have the chat delay and we're
trying to figure out he has some new
profiling PR and there's some overhead
with it but I think we're going to be
able to get an extra million SPS out of
it at the least. We're just trying to
figure something out. Yeah. So Jonah, I
think the test is wrong, right?
I don't think it includes the start and
stop only
wait profiler start.
I'm confused though because this dart
gets made above, right? So I can't tell
if it's included.
Let's just real quick
does not include the warm up. Okay,
cool.
So then I don't understand.
Okay. So then the profile function is
correct.
Wait then I don't understand why why
there should be this discrepancy then
they each do their own warm up which
isn't timed right
they should have better task coherency
if anything
synchronizes are here
but they only synchronize every bath
check hitters
So like I guess you could add you could
make this number bigger, right?
Like if you make it a thousand does the
over like do do the numbers close?
Because basically what I would like is
if you could figure out this gap here
between this 385 and this 287 because
this is a bigger gap than like this
entire kernel call here, right? So, this
needs to be explained. And if once you
figure this out, uh, if it's still worth
either graphing this or, you know,
optimizing this, you can probably get a
million SPS out of this.
An additional 1 mils would be huge. What
improvement? Uh there's some overhead on
some dumb ops that shouldn't have some
overhead in train.
Okay, I think that is everything for
now. Um, I'm going to go grab a mug of
tea.
Oh, yeah. What did this do? This did a
whole bunch of nothing.
Cool.
I'm going to go grab a mug of tea.
Um, Sounds good. Cool. Yeah. I'm going
to go grab a mug of tea in a moment and
then we will we'll continue cleaning
some stuff up. I'm going to look at a
couple things with the way we're doing
our advantage function. I'm going to
look at a couple things with 2048
and we will go from there. I'm a little
bit concerned though with um the sweep
because the sweep is finding really
weird args again. Just generally not
Not a great thing.
I will be back. Let me go boil some
water.
You can probably hit over 20 mil once we
delete torch.
But honestly, the biggest gain from that
is not going to be the SPS. The biggest
gain from that is going to be not having
[ __ ] torch in your codebase.
Okay.
Man, I have like could have been getting
good sleep. I don't know.
Right. Let's get ourselves back into the
mindset
I think this is what I did.
Hang on.
Okay. So
we do actually update ratio and value.
Um I'd simply forgotten that I did it
outside of the loop. Now
so unfortunately that means that we do
still need to be calling
uh the compute advantage function in
every loop
and the pryo in every loop. So, all the
stuff that I told
uh all the stuff I told Jonah still
applies.
Fine.
All the stuff I told Jonah still
applies.
So, that's one thing we don't have to
deal with today.
I'm take it a little slow for the first
bit here and um
and we'll figure out what I actually
want to refactor today. Let me get my
thoughts straight.
We have him looking at Jonah's looking
at profile.
Uh, Peru is looking at the end fact.
I have my own end profile checks that
are looking pretty good.
We have initial decent results, I'd say,
on 2048.
a little bit, but it's still replicable.
Say fairly replicable.
That's not a mug. That's a bowl.
No, it's a mug.
I remember at MIT I would end up having
to eat my dinner out of a mixing bowl.
The neurons just aren't firing today.
I'm like, hang on.
Funny thing is we can do numb.
This is even faster, isn't it?
Yeah, it's even faster.
That's ridiculous.
agent open. We will for little bits of
this. Not very much though.
And not for very much.
When do I know if an end is learning? I
have a slow laptop.
Even with a slow laptop, you're still
going to well, if you have a GPU of any
variety, with Puffer 4, you'll still be
able to have breakout training at
millions of steps per second. So,
you'll still be able to see it within a
few seconds.
If you don't have a GPU at all, rent
like a super cheap one on Bast. Get them
for a few cents an hour.
You can get them for practically the
price of the power that it would take to
run them.
Well, you need to be able like you need
to be able to have at least a GPU for
dev, right?
Like look,
if you um obviously you have to like
keep get synchronized and stuff, but
I think it literally will cost you $1
per day
to dev to just have a dev box here. So
3060 is probably fine. That's like 50
cents a day to dev. Where's something
that's like what's 10 cents?
70 Ti. Okay, look. This is literally
better than the GPU that I have on my
local device. And you can rent it for 9
cents an hour.
Cost you $1 per day to have this machine
for dev, right? You can just pause the
instance or whatever.
You can just have a setup script. It's
pretty quick.
They're not going to be as good.
Sometimes they nerf them a little bit.
So, they're not as good as if you had,
you know, your custom setup. You'll
still be able to train in seconds,
though.
Um, well, I'm not at the moment to be
fair.
I'll have it for very minor stuff later
today.
Let's just go look through a little bit
of um what the current structure is.
I want to see how clean we're feeling
about like how clean this is all
feeling.
Little bit just like little bits of
bloat here and there, right? Little bits
of bloat.
important end when you want the best
war.
You can run training for a really long
time on many different servers.
Um,
like you just want to run a really big
sweep, right?
But the thing is like you haven't
specified how hard the end is.
Like a lot of really important ends are
actually very easy.
If it's a really hard end, you're going
to want to like do some sort of like
small scale sweeps, right? And then
you're going to want to scale up the big
experiment.
There's probably some additional like
hyperp transfer stuff that um you want
to do if you have to scale way more than
we currently do.
I mean, there are lots of little things
here and there to clean up.
Maybe we'll just do this for a little
bit.
Cuz I'm finding all sorts of things that
I missed.
It's on host memory and is not
registered. Okay.
Uh lovely.
Oh, I see.
See why it's like this?
Wait. From blob.
Get exercises. Give you
pointer.
I could easily make this like if I were
really sticking to the C++,
I should probably make this just like a
a simple constructor.
My thinking here is uh this is not going
to be in C++ forever and I'd like to be
in more C.
I'm going to put these tags in for basic
refactor ops.
This one is fine because this one is the
opposite layout.
Yeah, I hate this.
Yeah, I totally hate this. What the
hell, man?
And this is not a f a bad way to start,
right? Just like clean up some small
things here and there. Figure out what
are the bigger things that need to be
cleaned up.
There's not much footage on work.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Look at all
this.
What do we
think about this?
Kind of a mess. Kind of clever. Kind of
in between.
This we can sort of sit think about for
a little bit, right?
Now this whole like this logic is very
stupid. I think
Hey guys, the GitHub like down or
something? What the [ __ ]
See if this works.
Everyone, I'm back.
Welcome
this is a terrible language.
Nobody should ever ever ever use
Isn't this Giga Jack? Wait, isn't this
like gig ga dragon
like you can't
I don't understand how it can be an
error to declare a type because it tries
to construct it even though you didn't
call it with pms like
that is awful.
I think I had a thing with um rock had
like a slight syntax. Nice.
There you go.
There you go, Jess.
Yeah, just ban just ban the bots and
solicitors Well,
I wonder if there's overhead to using
that crap.
No, we don't want to be making it every
time, right?
working to get your PhD? No, I got my
MIT PhD about two years ago. I'm working
full-time on making reinforcement
learning fast, insane,
and broadly available.
I build Puffer Lip. Puffer Lib is
currently at 15 million steps per second
training. That is 10,000 times faster
than anything I had during my PhD.
What are your thoughts on Rust? Does it
have any good libraries for mal? I hate
that language.
Yeah, I absolutely hate that language.
Um,
it's a absolutely awful to read,
absolutely awful to write language for
the sake of memory safety, which is not
even a like that's not even a bad class
of bugs to fix. It's only a bad class of
bugs in stupid languages that build a
bunch of crap uh, in a way that's
completely broken.
Like I get memory bugs in C++. I don't
get memory bugs in C because C++ likes
to allocate crap everywhere under the
hood without telling you.
See, you just manage your memory. You
free your mallex and you're done.
You sure as hell don't need uh a
language that forces you to write worse
code for the sake of catching memory
bugs.
It's not even get good. It's just
straight easier to write C than it is to
write Rust.
Like
there's just no point. You can go spend
a bunch of effort learning something
that's like just fundamentally worse.
You don't like what? You don't like
suffering? You know, you'd think I would
really like suffering with the amount of
crazy stuff I do on here.
Oh, and uh for reference, in case
anybody's wondering, no, I don't think
C++ is better. C++ is an absolutely
terrible language. I'm writing it
because I'm forced to write it because
I'm dealing with Lib torch. Eventually,
this will all just be nice.
Technically, CUDA is C++,
but CUDA is very well designed. You can
totally just write CUD to C. You can't
write um torch with C.
There are honestly very few things that
are awful to do in just RAW save. I
think string processing is pretty rough.
That's kind of one of the only things
though.
Where's N?
Oh, N.
Like even the fact that this is why the
[ __ ] is this and here? Why can't we just
have a pointer? Why do we have more
syntax? Screw this language, you know?
Let's see what's the simplest I can get
this looking and then we'll see if it's
worth it. It's going to be slightly more
lines of code, I think, but way shorter
lines.
What's the difference between C and C++?
Uh, you can read this code and there's a
nightmare of [ __ ] going on that you
need to have spent years and years of
C++ to actually understand everything.
This is one of our most complex
environments.
This is PRC. It's 3,000 lines. A first
year undergrad who's taken their first
systems course can read and understand
this whole file.
because there's nothing weird going on.
It's like you need to know what a
pointer is. You need to know what a loop
is. You need to know what a conditional
is. That's about it.
It's one kick 10,000 times versus 10,000
kicks once each.
Like the crazy part about like, oh, it's
more than OOP. Like, you could literally
do better OOP in C than you can in C++.
The only thing that's a little bit
sketchy, I suppose, is the uh the type
defs for functions, like for function
types.
Um, I'll admit that syntax is a little
bit jank, but if you want, you can just
put your function pointers in strrus and
then wow, you've reinvented OOP.
We're basically looking at the main roll
out function and trying to make this
thing less awful.
trying to trim the fat from chess
and like rendering with selfplay.
Wait, what do you mean rendering?
this way you don't have to understand
like torture stupid slicing thing,
right?
I think this is just for C++ kind of
bad.
Let me just make this the cleanest we
can and continue and not get too stuck
on this.
Uh, this this goes up here, my guy.
Right.
actually when do you want to copy the uh
the ender boards in?
I guess it makes sense to do it when you
copy in.
Okay. So, let's let me think when this
makes more sense to do because
No.
Still nice and fast. Okay.
slice.
Say this is just arms.
Do you still have the source code for
the Dota project? Like I I've never had
the source code for the Dota project. I
was not on that one. I was at OpenAI at
the same time uh interning, but I was
doing my own thing. If you mean my
little moa that I made, this thing is um
where is it?
This like small moa that does use the
Dota maps, but it's clearly not actually
Dota. Uh this thing is in Puffer Lib
uh mobile,
and you can play with it.
It's a pretty cool little game.
>> All right. What do we think about this
this uh roll out function?
>> I would prefer it if we didn't have all
the code tabbed in under the roll out
captured thing.
using their iPhones, not using their
phones to cheat.
That sucks.
Um, I mean not much. Just like super
grind everything.
This is the best result in all of
reinforcement learning.
They beat top pros at Dota.
It's pretty awesome.
This is one of the most useful papers in
the field as well.
work or life balanced up.
Well, like no, but I also don't believe
in the thing that they're doing because
like the problem with grinding nonstop
is that you also just end up doing worse
work.
open FL. No, that [ __ ] is a meme. If I
build a feedback loop for
by
So, LLM on uh RL on LM you get to use
the stupidest possible form of RL and
it's very slow.
So any form of LM RL is like usually
just ridiculously expensive.
You're grinding non-stop. This is not
considered grinding non-stop.
I've worked way way way harder than this
in the past.
I get plenty of sleep. I get good
exercise. I'm in good shape,
Like I get in some like serious
bodybuilding style training, some
serious powerlifting style training, and
a fair bit of running in every week. And
in fact, this is probably the least
exercise I do. I'm only doing maybe six
hours a week now of hard exercise. Um,
probably will be more soon.
Agents, religion, this just all stupid,
man. You're reading stupid [ __ ] on
Twitter.
Like, you're literally just watching a
bunch of parents walking at each other,
retiring.
Uh, you can do that. What is print? It's
way easier to do that when you're
younger. Like if I tried to work way
more hours, I would actually get less
stuff done now
because I wouldn't have I wouldn't be
sharp enough to actually do the smart
stuff that I need to do and I would end
up producing a large quantity of lower
quality work.
Also, they don't necessarily like comp
you crazy higher either there.
They don't have like particularly crazy
comp packages from what I've heard.
You're basically just betting on um
on the stock.
mathbound.
No, I think most researchers are
engineering bound.
Like the whole field of RL was screwed
over by bad engineering provably because
otherwise I wouldn't have been able to
make it this much better just by doing a
bunch of engineering.
Sometimes stuff is like every once in a
while somebody comes up with something
clever and mathy that's actually very
important but most of the time it's
stocks. Yeah,
I just have a bunch of texts and stuff.
They discovered ways to play the game.
Yeah.
You're not going to remotely get
anything like three B like three blue
one brown videos out of LMS. There's no
way.
like you're ascribing way way way too um
too much capability to the models
and I can bring any new breakthroughs
some but they're definitely missing
stuff.
I'm honestly I'm really don't care what
the big labs are doing all that much
other than the fact that people ask me
constantly.
There's some pretty awesome
breakthroughs just sitting here in RL.
How much more am I going to agonize
about having this thing inside of a that
one extra condition?
Is this better?
We duplicate one line of profile.
We untap everything.
I think this is better. Honestly, I just
hate having the whole thing tabbed in
like that.
I think this is much cleaner now.
We still have quite a bit of capture
crap and stuff, but it's a lot better.
Why do you stream, by the way?
Several reasons. It's enjoyable. Uh I
get at least the same amount of work
done on stream because typically any
time I spend talking to chat, I end up
getting distracted.
Anyways, it's great promotion for
Puffer. It's helped us dramatically to
grow the open source project. It's
gotten us tens of thousands of lines
worth of additional contributors that
wouldn't have seen the project
otherwise.
It's been massively successful
research at big labs compared to
academia
much faster pace. No, not necessarily
much faster pace. The thing is the big
labs are now very big and they're very
bloated.
Um
they're very very bloated. I I like it
really depends on the lab
and it's not necessarily more
engineering either. Like
for instance, it depends like a lot on
the lab, right? Like OpenAI's small team
engineering was awful. Their bigger team
engineering was very good. Deep Mind's
big team engineering and small team
engineering was awful because it wasn't
code-designed correctly.
Um, you know, there's a lot of overhead.
So in academia, people are optimizing
for a lot of [ __ ] and they don't
have any resources and their clusters
are a mess and they've got a bunch of
other stuff to deal with, but the big
labs are just big and um
you know they're trying to fit together
a jigsaw puzzle of different people and
most of the time that means that math
people are doing a bunch of math that
doesn't matter and engineering people
are doing a bunch of engineering that
doesn't matter.
Why do you stay at one place? I don't
stay at one place. I move around like
two or three times a year.
I spend time in Florida. I spend time in
Maryland. I spend time in California.
right, there you go. This works.
I think this is substantially cleaner.
I It takes a ton of time, but I think
it's substantially cleaner.
We're just going to do like this. Oops.
We're just going to do like this. Like
this. Like this.
Oh, s f vault. Lovely.
Absolutely lovely.
Lovely seg faults when we do this for
some god awful reason.
Why on
Leave this thing alone for now.
I don't I don't feel like dealing with
this stupid thing right now.
I'm going to go grab myself a new mug of
tea.
Try to make my agency target position.
The resort design transition based
reward. Uh just literally look at the
environment called target.
you give it uh a reward p uh
proportional to the delta distance to
the target. Specifically, the delta
distance.
I'll be right back.
Let me get some tea real quick.
Just black TS
Academia.
Yeah, government stuff is very very
slow.
Yeah, D like it's almost always that you
just have your end verse whatever wrong.
Puffer is very good. It should like it
insta solves a lot of problems. It's
almost always bugs in the sim.
How do you you pour hot water over it
and add some like a little bit of milk
and uh it's just like Trader Joe's Irish
breakfast tape.
Whatever.
gives me some caffeine without me having
like overly caffeinating if I'm drinking
this coffee all day.
Okay, this is probably where we have the
biggest amount of stuff.
that actually matters cuz I happen it's
just like
we start getting into the just jank of
Okay. So, this is where we're going to
um
Yeah, this is where we're going to have
to do um
this This is where we'll get CL for
refactor crap.
Not really happy with either of them.
I'm just using them for stupid
refactors.
I don't know if it's classic Riot. Like
it was a really cool looking game. It
just didn't do anywhere near as well as
their other games did.
Like I really have not seen almost
anything about that game online. I
played it I played the beta. It was
pretty cool. Unfortunately, I play
fighting game so it's like just get
merked instantly.
The only genre that's ever kept my
attention has been MMOs. Speaking of
which, we have the uh the side monitor.
I may look through the rest of this in
the meantime.
Is there a Hang on, I missed a message.
Is there a clean way to get like a video
of end training
develop through selfplay?
Uh, technically, yes. But probably the
easiest thing is to just run eval with a
few different checkpoints.
I mean, if we get it to be very good, we
can probably get some attention. It's
like, hey, uh, there's this new chess AI
that has never seen any human data and,
uh,
also is trained just by playing the
game.
It just plays the game a whole bunch.
That's all it does.
I think we can do the same fix here.
Maybe this
the kernel accumulation is a little
sketchy. I think.
to not do that. Um, like ever. Thank
you.
to fix this [ __ ]
I know actually this ratio and new value
this is dated. So we can delete this
which is nice.
Puffer chess. You guys get all the
credit.
Well, you can call it puffer chess or
you can call it puffer chest.
Buffer fish that just superior chest
fish.
That's funny.
Oh, actually you totally cuz it's
stockfish. You can just call it puffer
fish. That's hilarious.
The only problem is that's a very
ungooable name.
People just Google the puffer fish chess
engine or whatever.
Probably not, right? That thing is
ludicrously good. But we can try.
That'd be so funny.
beat stockfish.
But like stockfish you can set to be
ridiculously high, right?
Is it running it longer?
Yeah, pretty much.
I mean, I think if we get it log linear
and it's not just like awful awful
compute,
we can probably do it.
Wait, is this not Oh, it does log.
Hey, look. Cool.
Look, guys. Like we got our losses back.
Isn't that nice?
We have lost.
Look how cool.
Yay.
That's pretty nice.
Why am I so tired today? Let me go check
something.
You're [ __ ]
I think we can.
I think NVTX gets you proper timings
without syncs.
Did you expect chess to be this hard on
the learning front? Yeah.
Chess is a hard problem, Jess. You have
a legit problem there. It's also um
you're beta testing salt play at the
same
Oh, Kung sent me my run that I wanted to
look at.
he gets a way better result with this, I
think.
So, I will have to play with this.
He's got a way better result than I have
here.
Mine is not really trained for very much
time.
All right, we'll play with it.
It's got to be something though. Why
wouldn't it have that
Probably we're going to want something
better than this.
It's fine.
Oh, you can swap the profiler with this.
I think this is a cool thing.
So that's minus
50 lines of this.
So tired today.
Got to bed on time and bunch of good
stuff.
Hey, look at that.
That was very nice.
I see. Cuz I just have to fix the
dashboard. Cool.
Uh, that's nice though.
Oh. Uh, do you have any recommendations
with what the magnitude of the
cumulative
undiscounted reward should be
relative to the per step reward
magnitude?
Uh, no. Just the reward per step should
be somewhere between negative one and
one.
As long as it's between negative one and
one, you can tune. You can pretty much
just autotune the rest of it.
Well, the cumulative undiscounted reward
should be like, you know, the reward
frequency times the average reward sum,
right?
type of thing before carbs.
Uh, yes, Jess, you could like attempt to
run a random search or basing search or
what, but like yes, mostly people just
didn't run sweeps because they sucked.
So, RL did not work.
Not really a good way to do this, is
there?
There's the restroom.
Get more tea. I think super tired today.
We're back.
What is this thing?
All right. This event recording thing is
completely stupid, but
idiot tax.
This lasted way longer though. We used
it way less,
which is a good
progress. That's
We no longer have any CPU based timing
here.
And then pro names. Okay, the CN thing
I'm going to have to fix manually, but
no big deal.
Then
It's funky. Not the timings we want.
The only thing that's going to suck here
is the uh the end timings, right? Like
how on earth are we supposed to do end
We also don't need all these independent
timing sections.
16 whatever mil thing doesn't come with
really any overhead apparently.
I don't know why we have it like in
seconds or whatever.
This will be the initial thing that we
get done. Let's say
That's kind of cool though the way it is
cuz you now you have per epoch
kind of better.
Actually, this is nicer, I think, to
have it like this. Um, why the hell is
the miss time so high?
Does it add up?
It does add up.
I don't see how the hell that would be
possible, but maybe
We absolutely have to just like clean
this thing up. But for the sake of
having this thing done because I'm
ending stream soon, I've got um some
client work to do and very little energy
left to do it.
We'll push ahead a little bit.
We have some basic things to show for
the day will be the profiling
um
plus some nice clean up.
This is way closer to what we expect,
right?
Funny, the last iter gets messed up when
we do this.
But we got three and 90 in train.
Switches that forward.
It's not bad.
That's really not bad.
Let's just go through the last one last
thing here. I don't think that there's
actually going to be anything we can do.
I don't think that there's any
reasonable way we can profile the N,
which is kind of shitty.
Well, hang on. We actually, that's not
acceptable. We need a way to profile the
N.
All right, let me think of how the hell
we do this.
How in the hell do we do this?
It's just theoretically possible. Of
course. Duh. How wouldn't it be?
It's not a song though. It's the
problem.
Well, hang on. Is it I guess it is a
sum, right?
This is going to make a mess, but we'll
try it. And then we'll see if we're
still hitting 15 plus mil SPS.
We really need end time of some sort.
I think we're going to have to settle
for average.
Average should be quite accurate.
We'll let it do this crap for now.
I'm not pushing this though. It'll mess
up contributors.
Not until it's cleaned up.
I can probably clean it up in the
morning if I'm fresh to be fair.
Well, it'll work. I think the question
is whether it adds significant overhead,
which is why this is good for
prototyping it. Even if the code is a
mess, like if it's a positive result,
we'll know, oh, okay, you can at least
do this and then we can clean it up.
This now has way too many stats.
Interesting.
Uh, completely inaccurate, right?
Yeah. No, we're still getting 15 mil
plus
16 mil. So, this is really not that much
overhead. So, if we can get this to be
correct, well, we'll see.
Only honest split is forward plus device
to host.
that's fine. That's a reasonable split.
If we can even get that, that's awesome
because I imagine that um device to host
is going to be like nothing. That's just
moving actions back. We're not going to
get bottlenecked by that.
It also seems suspect to me. Harder to
say though.
It takes way longer to train, funny
enough, when you have um if you just
increase the steps. So that must mean
the learning and kneeling is very
important.
Let's see what the stats are for this
one.
Yeah. So, we can't copy the um
we can't measure copy overheads. Really
annoying.
Maybe when we merge them all, we'll see
if there's any meaningful overhead.
I think it's like less than 10% in any
event, right?
I'm going to have to clean all this crap
up tomorrow, but
it's okay for now.
As long as we get reasonable profile
numbers out of this thing.
I do want to make sure that we actually
have reasonable end numbers though. So
what we can do is we can run the uh the
benchmark end
and uh the benchmark end will
essentially tell us whether any of this
crap is correct
because the benchmark m should have
basically zero uh end of time when we
set it to that. Yeah, I'm fine.
Well, we've got a plan
and we'll make that probably the last
thing cuz I think I'll be ready to work
on the uh think we said two for the
work.
Yeah, we've got the uh the structure of
everything.
So that'll then be the dashboard. And
also this will make it no longer so like
ridiculously large.
Okay, good. Thing was not supposed to be
difficult.
both train top eight.
Good job.
Can't even do that.
Okay, now suddenly it gives me a
completely different [ __ ] number
which is lovely.
8% miss. That is actually what we
expected those like 8%ish
misk.
All right, here's what we're going to
do.
Okay, 0% end time. So, it is at the
least measuring end time probably
reasonably.
Let's rebuild it with ob size
124.
There should still not be any end of
time.
Good. It does increase the GPU time a
lot.
It would be nice to separate these but
not necessary.
And there's your end compute load.
Yeah.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
Yeah, we see for very fast ends
um miscellaneous is about 8%.
And uh when there's no end overhead,
it's about an 80 to 20 train to Ebel.
which is quite good. I'd say that's
quite good.
Oh, that also gives us a new peak
throughput, by the way, of um
was that 18 mil?
Does that mean breakout is still taking
up um
That does mean Breakout is still
literally taking up
a fair bit of the uh the compute, right?
Whoops.
We go.
I don't really know how to think about
this though to be fair because like
I'm going to have to think about that a
little more a bit.
That was one of the last things we
needed to be fair.
Oh,
monitoring and distributed practice. BML
lovely. Okay.
Jonah says um about 8% missed overhead
what's expected
do we have utilization stats at the
moment? I didn't even check.
We do have utilization stats.
I want them to be in C++ for whatever
reason.
Cool. So Jonah's fixed the overhead and
profiling which is good.
Let's not do this one right now. Let's
leave this one for later. I think we've
made enough progress for the time being.
We've got the dashboard clean.
We've got
uh no more Python profiling hook is
nice.
Stable 15 plus mil with all the
profiling even 16 plus very very low
overhead
and we've seen it get as high as 18 in
the benchmark end. So very nice.
I think what I'm going to do guys I'm
going to go get myself a quick snack
before I have to start the rest of this
work because I'm not going to have 10
minutes spare until dinner from now
until then. Um
and
I think I would normally stream after
dinner, but I'm pretty exhausted. I
think I'm going to call it an early
night.
I will be
most likely streaming a couple hours in
the morning tomorrow.
Probably cleaning up this profiling code
manually when I'm fresh.
We got a fair bit of the code cleaned
up. I think there's going to be some
more to clean up and train in addition
to the profile and creation, but it's
good progress. Like we're rapidly
getting towards something that is very
usable, which is which is quite nice.
Some stuff to clean up in the Python,
looking into stats and all that, but
nothing too too difficult.
Uh, for folks watching,
if you would like to support my work for
absolutely free, it's all open source.
Feed the Pupper Star on GitHub. Really
helps us out a lot. Join Discord to get
involved with the dev.